what's up everyone
bang bang it is lunch money time well
while she's trying to get rich the rest
of us trying to get our lunch money
right
we are here got that trillionaire energy
to kick off a wednesday i'm here with
the beautiful intelligent pulina evilova
marinova pompano
p-i-m-p my hair's a little static
staticky that's fine don't worry lunch
money is not sponsored by block five
block fighting got no static it just got
interest that's right you can earn eight
point six percent apy
in an interest bearing account go get a
block five
account and you will earn eight point
six percent apy
in that interest bearing account up to
i'm an investor i sit on the board
you'll be a happy user just like me
yesterday was interest day or monday or
whatever it was we got money we got paid
and that's what i'm here for i also got
a haircut they lined me up real nice
shout out miami let's go
why is my hair doing this because you
look real staticky
come on what's first jeff bezos richest
man in the world
second richest man in the world no no no
jeff second richest man in the world
because the greatest innovator of all
time elon musk the meme lord is the
rejection jeff bezos said tuesday he
will step down
a ceo leaving the helm of the company he
found it 27 years ago
bezos would will transition to the role
of executive chairman in the third
quarter of this year which starts july
1st
andy jassy what a great name andy jesse
okay uh the ceo of amazon web services
will take over a ceo
of amazon i have two questions one do we
think andy has been being group husband
being
has been being groomed for this role
since it's the head of aws it's probably
a bigger business than the rest of it
what i'm saying
so i think he's been being groomed he's
been groomed for this role so now he's
gonna step in it
second of all people are speculating
that bezos is leaving to focus on blue
origin because they
claim that is his true passion what do
we think
i think jeff bezos just called a goat
move that's right
goat g-o-a-t greatest of all time you
know what he did
jeff bezos said for 27 years i'm going
to be
relentless go to relentless.com where's
it go it redirects to amazon.com
fax go check that out he's owned that
url he almost
named amazon relentless but the man has
been relentless for 27 years he has
built a
massive business he's executed and
executed and executed and as he grew
he got to the top of the mountain he
looked around and he said mic
drop and he's walking away at the top
like a goku
so he's not walking so i i wanna so hold
on this is very very important
they're saying i want to reiterate jeff
bezos is not leaving he's going to be
executive
chairman super important role super
active in amazon success story
i have a question remember when bob iger
stepped to
stepped into the executive chairman role
and then we started seeing all these
stories about how
bob iger's actually very involved and
you just
won't let what does it bob see or
whatever do his damn job as ceo
so in my opinion it's like if you're
going to step away just like a step up
oh wait don't stay in the company
because you're if you're going to be so
hands on
hot take i actually like the fact that
he's going to be the executive chairman
it provides some for some continuity
during the transition he does but what
do you think about bob biden getting all
up in the business
business bob iger didn't want to step
down bob iger didn't want to deal
coronavirus that's why
bob iger got scared of the virus but
jeff bezos
he's doing the nice transition i'm gonna
leave in q3 i'm gonna step into the
executive chairman role andy jassy's
gonna step in as a ceo
and amazon is going to continue to
dominate
goat move that's what we're seeing right
here i know that y'all heard of goat
james that's uh lebron james goat
james now you talk about goat bezos any
any uh new england
fans here check out my the profile
dossier today is on
tom brady another goat
tom brady ate the goat you can't be the
goat listen now we're gonna get this
look she gets real mad when i say this
tom brady's very good tom brady has
actually been oh one of the best
quarterbacks of all time
one of but you cannot take the crown and
consider yourself the greatest of all
time the single number one best
if you met another quarterback in the
super bowl twice
and you walked away oh and two that's
right eli
manning is the goat eli manning is 2-0
against tom brady in the super bowl okay
okay then
tell eli manning to get his team to the
super bowl so they can play more often
no when he gets there he wins that's
what makes you great when you get to the
super bowl
and you play tom brady you say tom brady
i'm gonna stuff you in a locker i'm
gonna put your head in the toilet and
give you a swirly
you're gonna leave here 0-2 and what
kind of super bowls have you been
eli manning is the goat okay forget tom
brady let's go
moving on check out
theprofile.subsec.com
kia motors stock just had its best day
in more than two decades after news
media reported that it was closing in on
a major deal with apple
according to sources apple was about to
invest 4
trillion 1 3.6 billion dollars in kia
for a partnership to build a new vehicle
i knew that if apple was working on a
car it'd be something random like kia
all i must say is hey everyone going to
get in the game they think the car is
the new platform
but do not forget the greatest innovator
of all time
is out here literally just wiping the
floor
he's just cleaning up the floor he got
the brooms out
sweep city elon musk is not going to get
disrupted tesla is going to end up being
one of if not the most valuable
companies in the world and apple
is just going to watch them zoom right
back
i have a tiny bone to pick it has kind
of
really nothing to do with this but this
whole story is based on
one report from one uh south korean
newspaper
and then there's a whole article and see
it on cnn the largest one of the largest
news media websites
and then it says cnn business was unable
to verify
this report if you're unable to verify
the report independently
maybe don't spread news that could
possibly not be true
but they also said that they couldn't
verify it i mean it's basically like me
just tweeting that
you know all of a sudden amazon's gonna
buy clubhouse i might just start that
rumor all right ready
that's not true don't take me seriously
go ahead
stock trading app stash plans to
announce 125 million venture investment
to help fuel customer growth
but it's not looking to attract the type
of trader who might bet on games up how
are they going to
how are they going to differentiate the
new york
based company will announce series g
funding round led by eldridge with
participation from t row price and
others
the cash injection puts stash's
valuation
at a unicorn level 1.4 billion dollars
so the whole point of stash is they
basically made it really really hard to
day trade there's no margin
there's all sorts of there's no options
any of this stuff it's very
unattractive to day traders you can buy
and sell stocks when you want
but they did a lot of things around the
messaging around the product around the
uh different services that they offered
to discourage
the data let people do what they want
with their money
if people want a day trade they're gonna
lose their money that's fine but do they
know that they're gonna lose their money
or do they think it's fast money easy
cash let me get in there
what are you rapping i don't know fast
money easy cash
yeah get that on the t-shirt fast money
easy cash
no there's no such thing as fast money
easy cash you're literally the problem
you're the problem on the internet i
think no you're the problem i'm saying
that's what they think is gonna happen
but that's not it's
hard money hard cash no cash zero cash
negative cash
that's what you should actually have day
trading equals negative cash yeah
all right nobody wants negative stash
unicorn status what up
robin hood which has found itself in the
center of controversy after restricting
trading on equities including gamestop
will now run its first super bowl ad the
ad which will kick off what the company
says is the largest
ever brand campaign features the message
you don't need to become an investor
you are born one oh boy
oh boy this is dumb wait why
you want to know what they should do
they should have vlad
who's the ceo who's also from bulgaria
who dave porter is trying to put in jail
you should have vlad sit in front of a
camera and say
hi my name's vlad i'm the ceo of robin
hood
some of you may think that i don't want
you to trade
in fact though i would like you all to
get rich
by investing in the markets and he
should just talk to the camera
they should put some cool music in the
background maybe a little bit ambient
music
they should have some little uh things
come flying in from left and right maybe
a rocket ship one place
have a little price chart going up into
the right and just say hey
i'm not the bad guy the boogie man is
the existing system that i'm trying to
help you get better access to
they should put it on social media they
should tag a bunch of people and then
that'll go more viral than anything that
you're going to see at the super bowl
and my guess my guess is that by
explicitly saying we are not going to
become part of the existing system we
are not going to
continue to protect the status quo by
participating in this
absolute racket of the super bowl ads
instead we're gonna do it on social
media we're gonna go direct to the
people and our ceo is just gonna stand
here like a man and take the heat
people will appreciate it more i would
personally just go on and say no
easy cash no easy money here
okay that's what you would say yeah
maybe we should actually create a
robinhood ad for them
with you just saying robinhood no easy
cash
no easy money no what did i say earlier
no easy cash
if somebody said hard cash hard money
negative cash no
that was after that's okay oh i'll watch
it back
um yeah we know all right okay so
a tiny new species of chameleon has been
discovered
and it seems to be the smallest reptile
in the world
it is teeny it can fit on your little
finger here
um so it's called the nano chameleon and
it was discovered in the northern
regions of the island of madagascar
only two specimens have been found so
far but conveniently
it is a male and a female pair
explain to me explain to me why
madagascar always got these dinosaur
looking things i never did we never find
this stuff in the united states
it's never in the united states it's
never anything i don't want it publix
listen they never find this stuff in the
united states they always find in some
place like madagascar i don't even know
where madagascar
is on the goddamn map right but what i
do know
is that on madagascar they got all kinds
of dinosaurs aliens all sorts of crazy
ass things going on
what i need to understand is why does
madagascar in the comments let me let me
know why does madagascar get all the
aliens and the dinosaurs but we get none
of that united st
no other ones exist they've only found
two of this species
and conveniently it's a male and female
and it says
they the researchers performed micro ct
scans of the female and identified two
eggs and cider indicating she was mature
likewise the male's genitals seem to be
well developed
indicating he's also mature so here's
here's the thing how are they analyzing
the balls of a nano
uh this sounds like some jurassic park
stuff i feel like they were manufactured
and now we're gonna have these teeny
dinosaurs chameleons everywhere
yeah then they're gonna be real big and
next thing you know they're gonna be
like that
uh 37 gazillion foot uh t-rex that guy
bought for 30. remember when you want to
put that in our kitchen
uh listen if you got a dinosaur let me
know i'm in the market
i actually have a friend who i'm not
gonna say who it is who recently
he actually bought a dinosaur it's being
excavated right now and he paid uh seven
figures for it and it's gonna take two
years to get it fully out cleaned and
ready
and he was telling me about it and i
literally am trying to
see how i can convince him to bet me or
do something so that i could get the
dinosaur
some would call it a pomposaurus
i'm glad we don't do the joke of the day
anymore so people's ears don't bleed
okay come on hurry hurry
hurry i got this oh wait wait wait wait
no no we gotta ask the lunch man
well that's your job if you have one job
on the show i know my job is to find the
nano chameleons
um well you didn't find it somebody else
was a cyclist went to madagascar and
found it
casper comey casper cause
casmir
what areas do you recommend education in
the context of entering the block
blockchain g5 industries example for
work on your platform on typical
new business in online marketing
what would you say you got the questions
no no it's for you what areas do you
recommend
education in the content you should go
read and you should listen to things you
can listen to the podcast
you should go read the bitcoin white
paper you should go read books like
uh the bitcoin standard uh my buddy uh
and partner jason williams uh wrote a
book called uh bitcoin
hard money you can't f with hard money
easy money
oh my god and then also you should go uh
we have a new course if you go to
pomcryptojobs.com
in the top right it says crypto course
if you click on that you can sign up and
the next time that we run it yeah the
next time we run it
we give a crash course it's three weeks
i've been doing it every tuesday and
thursday i'm just out here slinging info
i'm slinging info educating the people
my hair is being crazy
because you look staticky you're
staticky all right
ready michael w you both seem like hard
workers on top of having this podcast
how much social media do you consume
including instagram twitter netflix etc
do you set aside time per day to be on
these or do you have self-control enough
to get your work
done first you go first zero
self-control
all the self-control zero all zero all
um yeah no i primarily use
twitter i don't really my notifications
are off for
any other social media actually i have
selected notifications for twitter
and then um yeah i can i consume a lot
of twitter because that's where i find
articles that's where i
you know hear what people are doing out
there in the world
uh but i don't do like tick tock and
like instagram not really
so your boy lives on the internet
literally i was born for this
i'll go out on the field every single
day and i destroy it
i'm just out here living on the internet
i'm excited i'm enjoying it
i'm having fun on the internet she tries
to get off the internet i'm trying to
get on the internet if i can spend more
time on the internet i'm there tell me
where the party is i'll be there
i'll be the moderator i'll be the guest
i'll be the
star i'll be the supporting cast
whatever you need if it's on the
internet i'm there
i just have parting words for everybody
on the internet
don't be bullies be kind to your friends
you're just saying that because you
watched the bachelor last night and they
were bullying people
i don't call them they were awesome they
were calling someone like
escort that's what they did they called
him one yeah he watches the bachelorette
yeah
hey i'm i'm in on the cattiness now let
me tell you i've never seen that show
before
she showed it to me it's it's like a a
sports game but
literally these women and these men are
just saying
crazy stuff it's nuts so what i do is i
try to uh guess what chess moves
everyone's gonna make
he does do that i know he's gonna win i
already know who's gonna win don't have
have you been reading the spoilers no no
spoilers i don't know about any sport
what i don't know is it's gonna be a
great day on the internet i hope you
guys have a great day go to blockby.com
and we will see you
tomorrow trillionaire energy
negative cash bang bang hope you guys
enjoyed this episode of lunch money as
much as we did
and don't forget lunch money is now
sponsored by block five so go check them
out there's a link in the description
that you can click on
i'm an investor a user and a huge fan
what you're a bigger fan of block five
than you are of me
block five is my second favorite thing
in the world behind polina they've got
three products
they can give you a us dollar loan you
can earn up to 8.6
interest on an interest bearing account
or you can buy and sell cryptocurrencies
on their crypto exchange
i personally use the interest bearing
account there's not very many places
where you'll find up to 8.6 interest on
a deposit in an interest bearing account
go do your own research there's risks
associated but 8.6
is pretty compelling so click on the
link in the description say thanks to
the folks at blockfy
subscribe to our channel like the video
annoy pulling in the comments
and we'll see you guys tomorrow and be
kind to your friends